what many didn't know is underneath it
all chesley was reeling from
debilitating depression
jada pinkett smith breaks down in tears
on red table talk while discussing the
death of former miss usa chesley crist
who died by suicide after a long battle
with depression she was 30 years old
good to be here it's healing for me to
talk about chesley chesley's mother
april simpkins sat down at the red table
for her first interview after her
daughter's death discussing chesley's
final words and the legacy she left
behind she truly was my best friend
she was the first person i talked to
when i woke up we would literally just
go about our morning
facetiming each other she'd be putting
on her makeup
i'd be getting myself ready at my desk
how's your day what's going on so to not
have that makes mornings
awful for me yeah
but
i don't know that i'm going to get over
the grief i'm trying to accept that reef
and i are going to do life together the
mother of six went on to explain how she
knew chesley was destined for great
things since the moment she was born and
although chesley was successful on tv as
an extra correspondent and always
smiling and bubbly on social media april
says her battle with depression was
something she hid
this was not
her first suicide attempt she'd
attempted suicide before and it was
after that first attempt
that she and i grew very close and
i wanted her to feel comfortable calling
me and she began taking all the right
steps she began seeing a counselor she
was getting good sleep at night she knew
all the things to do april then recalls
the day of the tragedy
sunday mornings chesley knows i go to
work out she was leaving her exercise
class on the morning of january 30th
when she noticed a text message from
chesley first i'm sorry
by the time you get this i won't be
alive anymore
and it makes me even more sad to write
this because i know it will hurt you the
most
i think at that point on your blacked
out
because by the time i read the text an
hour had passed
april shared that she didn't read the
entire text immediately revealing that
she had hurried home to call her husband
and figure out what they had to do but
she went on to read to the ladies at the
table chesley's last words to her and
full i love you mom
and you are my best friend and the
person i've lived for for years
i wish i could stay with you but i
cannot bear the crushing weight of
persistent sadness
hopelessness and loneliness any longer
i've never told you these feelings
because i've never wanted you to worry
and because i hoped they would
eventually change
but i know they never will they follow
me through every accomplishment success
family gathering
friendly dinner i cry almost every day
now like i'm in mourning chesley's
message continued she said that she's
wished for death for years and it's a
weight she didn't want to share with
anyone i love you more than any person
i've ever known
you've done nothing wrong
you've done everything right
i no longer feel like i have any purpose
in life
i don't know if i ever really did
chesley's final text revealed what she
hoped was waiting for her on the other
side of her pain so i will leave and
rejoin god in heaven and hope to find
peace there
i don't want to leave but i genuinely
feel like i have to if i want to escape
my loneliness that feels like it has no
end you are the perfect mom
and i will love you forever
even in death chesley ended her message
by letting her mom know to feel free to
share this message because they should
know how great of a mom she is april
also shared her hope that opening up
about her daughter's passing will
encourage others to be kinder to those
who have mental challenges back in 2018
et spoke with jada about the importance
of covering heavy topics and discussing
mental health at the red table you know
i i really want to
be able to have
it takes practice to have those
difficult conversations
with kindness
and consideration
and it's just something that we have to
continue to practice because if we don't
talk about it
we're not going to get to the other side
we're just going to you know
things are just going to stay
in the cracks and fester
so the more that we can bring these
difficult subjects to light and talk
about it the more we can purify these
subjects and bring them into something
new and so
that's why it's important for me